we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here is a caller who
is really really really excited that
Republicans are taking control of the
house in January listen to this guy
Republicans now control the house
no experience for for paybacks for all
those low levels Democrats
and then and smelly smelly Pelosi
oh yes the caller wants payback for
those Democrats and for smelly Pelosi
I hate to break it to this caller by the
way he doesn't actually sound that
excited I hate to break it to this
caller but Republicans have already made
clear what they are going to do in the
two years that they're about to control
the house number one they're going to
obstruct anything Democrats try to do to
help the country
they'll try to get in the way that's
number one and number two Republicans
will investigate Hunter Biden the
payback for all of the Terrible Things
Hunter Biden did to this country is
going to come
from investigations into Hunter Biden
which don't make any sense he's not
running for anything he's not in any way
involved in Joe Biden's presidency we
know what's coming it's going to be
pathetic it's going to be a joke on
today's bonus show the New York city
mayor
says that New York City is going to
treat the mentally ill
even if they refuse treatment or try to
refuse treatment what's going on here
we're going to talk about what's
happening in New York City Twitter is
reportedly now having trouble making
payroll
some employees are reportedly not being
paid on time at Twitter uh-oh what is
happening there and number three England
and Wales are now minority Christian
countries based on the latest census
what does the data mean what are the
majorities and what is the future of
England and Wales as what have
historically been Christian countries a
very interesting situation and is the
same coming to the United States the
demographics May well be pointing in
that very same direction all of those
stories we are going to be talking about
on today's bonus show which you can sign
up for at joinpakman.com also I want to
ensure
that everyone who wants it has
downloaded the free white paper on
consider getting people who disagree
with you politically to reconsider their
views it's called building arguments
without Burning Bridges you can get the
guide for free you know people write to
me and they say David I'm I have tears
in my eyes because I want the white
paper but I can't afford it the white
paper is free you also do not need to
email me for the white paper I had
people emailing me saying David can you
send me the white paper no it's all
completely automated and available to
you whenever you want it here are the
steps you go to davidpackman.com guide
you type in your email address and we
email you the white paper it's
completely free it's completely free
it's completely free over 1500 people
have now downloaded the white paper
unbelievable numbers get that get the
bonus show get the commercial free audio
and video streams of the show do the
entire thing and I will see you on the
bonus show in mere moments